Hey
found a dungeon so this first term is
just gross and wet but then but then
this room tinkerer fantasy oh oh it
keeps going it smells a lot like motor
oil and there's a canoe because you know
and then up here this there's a hole
don't don't worry about it feel like
it's necessary for me to take this
opportunity to to hang out in this spot
and talk a little bit on tour is a
strange thing you see it from the front
for a long time there's something sort
of undeniably like cool about people who
are up on the stage like they're
physically lifted off the ground it's
less glamorous in person but it's still
cool I mean this is amazing I'm pretty
sure I shouldn't be down here but it's
amazing there are hard work elements
there are boring elements but it is a
honor and a privilege to be able to do
this with people you like I hear someone
coming which is terrifying to me is it
someone I know is it a monster is it an
employee to tell me to leave only by
waiting will we know I'm scared hello
hello the good news is I can protect
myself if it comes to that it's a
saxophone monster what are you doing in
the dungeon saxophone monster
this isn't great gotta do a lot of this
to move this that was a non ideal
driving day London late it was pretty
short feeling is very easy to make
people in music look cool and it's also
like financially advantageous to do it
they look of an image like a brand
around an artist is vital to their
success it's getting to be a lot of how
like everybody presents themselves on
the internet to show everybody our best
moments and cut out all of the
unpleasantness all of the dirt and more
than ever we have ways to get scored on
our performance we can Instagram likes
and snapchat views and pings of your
special cake on Pinterest I worry about
that because just like how in school we
start to focus on the things that are
easily quantifiable maybe we're gonna
start to do the same thing in life I
mean we've always done it with dollars
so now we have all these other metrics I
think that might encourage us to forget
about the things that maybe aren't as
want to viable but are in the end much
more valuable like having great people
in your life helping take care of those
people doing things that you're proud of
regardless of the opinions of the masses
strengthening your communities and being
a part of something bigger than yourself
that's just the thing that I've been
thinking a lot about as we drive through
the country which has been wonderful
thank you so much to everybody who's
come out to the shows and John I'll see
you on Tuesday